[Music]
what's going on guys
hey so you'll watch anything good on TV
right now do you need some suggestions
of something cool to binge you're in the
right place because today we're doing an
episode called what to binge and we've
got a couple of real fine TV Minds here
to talk about it with first oh you know
her from FX movie download and she's a
host on screen junkies news Sasha pearl
raver hello how redneck
welcome back to the party Sasha and he
is the associate editor at Nerdist Kyle
Anderson hi Hal thanks for having me
back each of us has brought in a few
shows and some of these shows you know
they're not shows you've never heard of
but maybe you haven't gotten around to
them yet and we're going to give you the
seal of approval that like yeah sit down
and watch the hell out of this thing
right yeah
Sasha give us a show that's binge worthy
there's a mini-series on stars and it is
so consumable it is called flesh and
bone so it's about a girl who comes to
New York and auditions for a ballet
company I know I know I probably lost
some people here but hold on there's
lots of boob so kinda sack I'm Becky and
every single episode ends with us oh oh
and you have to go to the next one
because it's so intense it was written
and created by miral Wally Beckett who
was a writer on Breaking Bad and wrote
my favorite episode from the series
which is Ozymandias which was the second
of the last episode in series yeah
super-good awesome yeah Kyle talked to
us
Voltron legendary defender yeah this is
my new favorite show what's eat - good
kitty
i watch it so fast as a Netflix show so
you get to watch full seasons if you
remember Voltron from the 80s I had a
Voltron and everyone did was so cool I
can so I watched it for nostalgia first
of these you know pilots who get to fly
in robotic lions that come together to
form a giant robot guy with a sword it's
so good but add to that the writing and
directing style of the people who did
Legend of Korra and Avatar The Last
Airbender and you have one of the best
written kind of adventure shows I think
on TV right now and the it's gorgeous
looking they maintained the animation
style that I remember just being a kid
and that was why I love that show so
much yes they didn't try to like update
it and make it cool for the new kid
Sharon like this is what was you're
still going to love it children today
will love it
defenders of the universe on it's got a
nice ring to it I'm going to recommend a
show that is still on the air it's going
into its third and final season the
leftovers on HBO disappearance of two
percent of the world's population it
basically explores what the world would
be like if a rapture type situation
actually happened the acting is
fantastic just the psychological and
ethereal journeys that these characters
in the subject matter delves into it's
really some of the most fascinating
explorations of like the afterlife and
that kind of thing the second season one
of the best seasons of television I've
ever seen I love my family I loved him
and why did you try to kill yourself it
comes back for its final season April 16
good stuff yeah Sasha
so speaking of final seasons I have a
show that I loved that lasted three
seasons and when I found out it was the
last episode nobody knew nobody saw
coming were you guys fans of penny
dreadful yeah
oh did not yet basically this show is
London 1900s basically and it's every
great supernatural character that we've
come to love you've got Frankenstein you
got Frankenstein's monster your first
bone has returned
Eva Green doing I cannot believe she
never got many for her work yeah I
cannot believe she never got money I'm
that girl no much incredibly
underappreciated
yeah droll she's always great she's
wonderful that direction is incredible
the characters even though it is sort of
a supernatural story you really really
care about and it is a very visible show
probably available on Hulu because it's
a Showtime Showtime show so it's on Hulu
and you can get it through Showtime
access Kyle throw another one at it it's
the most rewatchable comedy I think I've
ever stand it is Parks and Recreation
which you can start you can skip I think
the first six episodes because they were
finding their footing same with the
office I don't like watching those first
six episodes are a little rough for me
start with season two and then you're
off to the races and then that one's one
I don't mind that there's like 22
episodes because you just want to keep
hanging out with those people oh yeah
one of the funniest shows still how is
this a child side soda
well it's roughly the size of a
two-year-old child if the child were
liquefied it sort of became like The
Simpsons where the town of Pawnee
Indiana became its own sort of like you
recognize the different side characters
like perd hapley i'm perd hapley and I
just realized I'm not holding my
microphone if you've watched all of
Parks and Rec uh go watch it again
because you'll be surprised at how
rewatchable it is change yourself so the
past couple of years we've had sort of a
resurgence of these true-crime shows
like the jinx making a murderer I'm
going to go a little bit of a deeper cut
which is from 2004 I believe it was on
IFC and it's called the staircase it's
about this mysterious death of a man's
wife and he is charged with the crime
and I'm not going to tell you whether
he's innocent or guilty and you may even
walk away from the show not even knowing
truth is lost universally truces of no
meaning whatsoever like so many of these
true crime real-life crime dramas uh
it's a mine oh yeah like I've heard only
the best things about it it is
compelling watch
yeah Sasha so for me no binge is
complete without a food show the best
food showed binge
that's delicious from by planned it's
the best we got just come over here hey
put in a microwave not feeling that that
might have turned me off of duck for a
long time
Action Bronson yes Hrothgar yes granted
I used to be a chef he was a chef and
basically he adores food and on best
delicious he travels the globe to the
best restaurants in the world
and since sound with michelin-starred
chefs and eats the food and watches them
taste stuff like it's him with like
Daniel blog and he's like beautiful
restaurant in New York he's walking
through wearing like a Knick starter
jacket the Knicks and he's like oh you
got a cool bar scene going on so yeah
that part is when he goes to taste the
food because he's got this gigantic
beard he does picks it up and pulled it
back and he has so much joy and
enthusiasm for the food I've never had
anything that tasted like this in my
life
he's one of those dudes Action Bronson
who you just want to be around him um
sold Kyle you got one more for I got one
more yeah I it's hard to say that I want
to watch hours and hours on end of
sketch comedy because you know there's
ups and downs but for me I could easily
do this with every episode of Monty
Python's Flying Circus that it is no
bull dick
it's got everything that I want we had
ridiculous humor coupled with like
references to Chaucer and stuff like
that and it's just such a weird and
bizarre show and they will just give up
on sketches and it's like yeah we have
no punchline here by just getting to
City what every part of it is silly
until it is to live right get on with it
it's one of the funniest shows still
it's it's you know everyone should watch
it for religious purposes such
groundbreaking television really like
would we have the great sketch shows of
today yeah without Monty Python's Flying
Circus it's like the granddaddy of them
all yeah and just holds up it really
does yeah I mean I feel like most
we'll have it seen a Monty Python and
the Holy Grail which is a wonderful
movie but like this sketch show is where
like all the best stuff is in my opinion
heck yes thank you for that this one is
it's a show that many of you have
probably heard of probably many of you
have seen but if you haven't what are
you waiting for black mirror on Netflix
a cautionary tale of the future a
cautionary tale of the present
technology it's pervasiveness the
government putting our trust in
computers man this show it's ok it's
going to make you a little bit paranoid
but it's also going to entertain the
hell out of you and it's somewhat like a
modern day updating of the twilight zone
it's important that you realize there is
a small medical procedure involved sorry
very name I'll just say this watch the
first episode watch the very first
episode of the first season if you are
not hooked by that first episode that
involves a pig the Prime Minister of
Great Britain and I will say no more
great TV guys um I just realized I have
so much TV to watch uh what is your
personal recommendation for a show to
binge and what's your favorite binge
watching experience let us know in the
comment section below we want to know I
want to thank my guest for an awesome
conversation gosh uh pearl raver Thank
You Kyle Anderson thanks for coming back
with the pleasure and thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal
Rudnick's hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
hey guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers
movie fights and more